[Musik]
hallo herzen filter installiert werden
heute gibt eine leckere hefezopf und
zwar dürfen hier also ich hab einen
gebacken ohne rosinen sender morath mag
nicht so fern ist ja viel organisieren
also ich glaube wirklich 70 prozent der
menschen mögen keine rosinen im eben
hefezopf und 30 prozent zu senken
sie mögen es ganz gerne aber ich mache
auch gerne mit schokostückchen die habe
ich heute mit drin und noch hart mit
zucker obendrauf unseren hierfür ist ob
ich wirklich viel arbeit
ihr müsst nur ein bisschen zeit mit
einem berechnen damit der hefeteig eben
schön aufgehen kam damit dass ihm schon
locker sitzt und ja heute verrate ich
euch ein kleines geheimnis wieder
richtig schön saftig bleibt jetzt zeige
ich mich aber erst einmal die zutaten
für den hier gezeigt brauche ich einen
halben meter 8 bis zwei esslöffel warmes
wasser 500 gramm mehl 1 1 getroffen
extrakt einen teelöffel salz 200
milliliter war mit 80 toms verlassene
mutter und später brauche ich noch ein
eiweiß zum bestreichen
etwashausens drucker und für den
hefeteig muss 200 gramm backfest
showtruppe wer zuerst wenn man die täter
nehmen
die lese ich eben war man weiter aus so
verteilte sich dann auch richtig gut
und da kommt auch ein bisschen zucker
mit dazu und rhythmen im schnee geben
[Musik]
mit einem vortrag zu bereiten das heißt
ich gebe es die hilfe mit 4 1 und lebte
auch noch ein bisschen fitter und deckt
das ganze ab und lassen so ist erstmal
ein bisschen aufgehen und zwar bewegte
vorteig jetzt ist es zeit später
insgesamt schneller aufgeht und als ich
dann hier versagt zb am abend vorher
zurücktreten möchtet könnt ihr auch noch
ein bisschen weniger hefe nehmen dann
habt ihr noch weniger hitze geschmack
weil er dann einfach länger im
kühlschrank aufgeben also je länger man
hierfür zeigt aufgehen lässt umso
weniger hilfe benötigt
das lässt hier kurz stehen ich kann
jetzt hier ein bisschen temperatur
einstellen
ansonsten stellt jetzt den vorteil
einfach an einem warmen ort oder lasst
ihn was den traktor etwa 15 minuten
stehen
ich mach das jetzt hier auf etwa 35 grad
und lassen 15 minuten aufgeben
[Musik]
gibt man schön dass der vortrag
aufgegangen ist und den restlichen zeigt
aber die rast an zutaten zufügen teig
verkneten
das heißt es kommt das ganze mail
betreiben dann beste zocker gebe ich
auch gerne wandel extrakt mesrine dass
man richtig tollen geschmack jetzt auch
nur das idol und war deswegen den weiß
gedeckten austrocknet das heißt wenn ihr
nur eigelb mit rein gibt bleibt daher
bis das einzige saftiger und jetzt lasse
ich mir nicht aktivierten und gibt da
noch die flüssige würze mit rein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie beträgt jetzt etwas zeit zum kino
und kneten und ihr seht doch fertig ist
wenn er sich vom schlüssel rand schön
blöd zufrieden bist ein wachstumsplus
vettel damit meine arbeitsfläche da gebe
ich den teig und formieren schnell zu
einer kugel zusammen
und jetzt bitte ich die schüsse gebt ihm
zeit zurück und gibt auch noch ein
bisschen drauf dann trocknet ähnlich aus
ihr könnt den antrieb aber auch zum
beispiel mit etwas mehl bestreuen
ich las den teig jetzt nicht aufgehen er
ging dafür ab und lassen für etwa sechs
wochen aufgehen sieht dass sich das
doppel hat und danach gibt's meint
weiter ist der hilfsaktion auf gedanken
wie man blieben
und jetzt nehme ich ihn aus der schüssel
heraus und fette ganz leicht meine
arbeitsfläche damit derzeit am strand
lebt und jetzt nehme ich an der stelle
die schoko tropf und schnee das jetzt
ein wir können jetzt auch weil wir keine
chance obwohl zum beispiel routine
nehmen
da bin ich aber empfehlen damit sie
nicht verbrennen sie vorher in rom
einzulegen oder in abzupassen beispielen
und startet nur dort keine rosinen leben
schoko druck
[Musik]
derzeit wird in drei teile eingeteilt
und die frauen jeweils zu einem langen
strand
[Musik]
die treibt strenge die habe ich jetzt
regen an der ecke links und jetzt wie
ein hardtop geflochten das heißt immer
von außen in die mitte
[Musik]
hier unverbindlich saisonsieg und rückte
zusammen und legte damit runter dann
sieht man einfach kein abschluss
[Musik]
nehme ich den job vor sich verändert und
legt ihn auf meine dauer back frühe und
das schiebe ich schon gern immer ein
bisschen zusammen so dass eine schöne
form bekommt und den werde ich jetzt
sogleich abdeckung mit ein bisschen
frisch poliert und eben noch mal etwas
30 bis 60 minuten ausruhen lassen
so geht auch noch schön hoch und wird
eben am ende richtig schön locker
[Musik]
wer bitteschön aufgegangen und sitzt
seit ich ihn mit eiweiß bestreichen und
dann noch mit haare zucker bestreuen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und mit der hilfe profis im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 170 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 30 35 minuten gebacken
[Applaus]
der hefepilz gebacken und ich habe noch
abkühlen lassen
am liebsten esse ich ihn ja noch sehr
warm aber warm ist dass ich nicht gut
schreiben
und man muss einfach sagen dass ein
hefezopf was denn eigentlich im ort
gleich essen sollte oder vereinbarungen
zwei tage spiele kommen wir nicht mehr
wobei ich finde dann kann man ihnen
auftreten also gerade in den tropen
reinlegen mit butter bestreichen oder
mit meiner frau lag am besten so richtig
alle vier stück hingeben und gibt auch
leute die mögen ist auch ein stück
garner und dann gibt teilweise die
lieben ist außen stück für den er ins
leben also die hacker auf einander genau
in rhede smiley erst und das war richtig
locker und richtig so sieht es ist dann
sagte ich mir probiert und es ist ja nur
wohnen grundrezepte heißt ihr könnt ihr
auch abwandeln wer möchte das nicht
getrogen stahl abhängig
mit mit sitz in köthen ii einfach
verändern sie fühlen auch die schuhe
berufsweg lassen guter essengeld genau
motorflex lassen mit futter nur essen zu
verlängern um rsr st hier ist das erste
mal probleme mit der fachrichtung auch
bei uns vermehrt nach neun jahren als es
auch jemanden damit überraschen wolf
dann geht auch babys - blog.de
das steht noch mal das genaue rezept und
fand hier das rezept nach macht werden
wird doch ein foto auf facebook oder
instagram und wir schauen dass wir schon
so genau deshalb eigens ein eiweiß kommt
also fenster nächste mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]